okay hello everyone
should be live it's 9 p.m. Monday night
hmm
my phone says I'm live so I think I'm
live so it's going to be kind of a
normal stream with exception that I'll
be following my Youtube subscriber
counts because I should be hitting
10,000 with the next hour a couple hour
is hopefully not more than that because
I do want to sleep tonight
but I'll be taking challenges so if
people want to challenge me I have zero
pending challenges currently so anyone
wants to play hello Lucy moody hello
echo hello Bea Fox hey double Opie black
double oh thanks for the 200 bits and
thank circle for the sub desert booj
thanks for the kind words so I'm still
waiting on the challenge if people don't
know how to challenge me you can type in
the challenge command if I can make this
work except I just misspelled challenge
people know what to do okay I'm gonna
play T YT why the nice guy and hopefully
the lag won't be too bad let's play E 4
and 9 F 3 and let's play a Spanish I
haven't played a Spanish in a while
hello chest with Chris 9 f 6 what do I
recommend against 9s 6 we could Castle
play a Berlin
he's he's rated like mid-1500s and would
be impressive if he just played mainline
Berlin
okay d6 is playable I mean d4 looks
reasonable here just because of the pin
it makes sense to challenge the Simon
right away maybe even threaten d5 hello
- mini full and Colter Wilson and
cyberwarfare I'm not accepting any
congratulations yet I still need 33 more
subscribers what's left almond samani
good to see you back that's a lot of Yas
so now it's a question ooh Bishop g4 the
counter pin d5 let's play d5 there's
only one move one reasonable move for a
black in this position to essentially
not lose material
yeah a Six's is the best move and now I
have to think because I have a few
options I can take the night immediately
I could play Bishop a4 play Bishop e2 I
play Bishop a4 b5 we trade my c6 pawn is
weak but his a4 pawn would be weak I'm
tempted just to play Bishop e2 so I
don't know what else is better and I
could take the knight take on b7 rook b8
Knight c3 hmm I'm gonna play Bishop e2 I
don't trust those lines because in many
of those lines I'm giving away the
bishop here and here at least I'm
keeping just a nice space advantage and
I'll continue very soon with some move
like Knight c3 premature celebration
it's slightly premature but I'm not
celebrating yet I'm just anticipating a
celebration so hopefully it will come at
some point
yeah Knight c3 there's cases where I
maybe I would like to play c4 first Wow
Queen c8 so sometimes people quit play
Queen c8 cuz if I play h3 they want to
take on h3 but I think that would be a
bad sacrifice for black this is actually
a common mistake
players like prematurely sacrifice but
okay he retreats let's continue
developing and I think I just want to
like try the squeeze strategy where I
just I keep controlling more space keep
improving the position and keep
restricting the opponent's so all of
this looks pretty standard I'm gonna
play Knight d2 defend the pawn may be
unleashing my earth pawn
we'll start with f3 Wow I'm in some
money with a massive gift of subs and
flair one flyer zero with a thousand
bits people are so generous it's coming
out of nowhere and he subs was that was
10 subs thanks I'm in some money why did
I take on c6 oh he played c6 cuz and my
pawn was slightly concerned I'm gonna
play a5 with idea to just clamp down and
next move I want to play maybe Knight c4
Knight b6 so welcome to all the new subs
thanks so much I'm so money
anyone who just became a new sub you
have to think I'm and Somani violet
green Dino Lucy moody chest with Kris
double o P block double o grey Hatter
desert guj let me make a move first
we'll play Knight c4 this looks
reasonable and ER is by lunge basta GG
tactical wizard it's name I haven't seen
in a while and chests quack
welcome guys okay so he's traded off
essentially my worst piece LightSquared
bishop and now I'm left with some very
good minor pieces now I'm moving slowly
because I've been focusing I've been
getting distracted rather than focusing
but maybe I can start focusing more on
the game prepare Knight b6 which he just
misses and this is a triple fork cuz d5
is hanging I might be more inclined to
take on d5 then take his rook because
he's threatening to play pawn d4 his
Queens gonna move somewhere
and the sub sound never stops yeah I'm
gonna take on d5 with a pawn keep
attacking his Queen and then I'll
probably take the rook ooh
well Wow
people are just being so generous people
giving subs and bits and free pieces now
the rook and the bishop are both
attacked forks everywhere now the Queen
and the king of tact and he's gonna lose
his a pawn in the end that's especially
hurtful ouch ooh Lucy - but he's gonna
lose c6 I'm being very greedy taking
every pawn I can ooh okay he's at almost
trapping the Queen but okay Queen b7
this pawns a goner hello toilet noggin
tore the noggin I tried to play the
exchanged Spanish this game but my
opponent played the Berlin just to go
back for toilet noggin we got to this
position and then he played some kind of
weird Berlin without a knight a key for
and then okay then it was fun
so let's okay let's take on c6 maybe
I'll take on f3 with the Queen thanks to
the cooler
two months in a row
so how much material is white up lights
up a queen a pawn and a knight it's a
lot of material so the goal should be
just to meet as quickly as possible
maybe I'll set up and the stages mate or
maybe not
and Bishop g6 is a defensive piece but
I'll try
probably the quickest way to win is just
to promote the pawn plus 13 is that the
valuation of this position okay another
free bishop this has to be at least like
plus 20 if not like force meets yeah I
wouldn't be surprised if the computer
says like made in satin or something but
okay let's just attack f7
attack the rook
hey it's a game over the last three subs
were all desert booj I don't know if it
says that but thanks if that's the case
oh the last three subs on YouTube okay
there's a difference between subs on
Twitch and subs on YouTube yeah my
opponent was really nice to me this game
living up to his username Bishop g4 is
interesting I wasn't entirely sure what
was going on I felt like what I felt
like white should have some advantage ah
did you take any five make some sense
actually
so I played D five and a six
I think Bishop e2 is the best move it's
highest-scoring move okay let's play a
new player Siri give me a random number
between one and five numero Cinco
Tabasco sauce okay good luck Tabasco
sauce cannot take the sky lightly
provisional rated and rapid any advice
for building opening repertoire mm rated
and leach s rapid player yeah when
you're building an opening repertory you
should save basically all of the lines
that you play on a regular basis and
save it if you use chest space I mean
that's probably the best tool for like
building a repertoire but probably the
easiest tool is justly chess study and
then you can save everything and and
then over time add on to it and just
save like the one lion that you would
play and then save how the Poynting can
basically deviate and branch out in
different variations let's play in them
though I'm gonna play the nimzo-indian
is this GM Feingold no this is this is I
am Eric I am NOT fine gold fortunately
or unfortunately I don't know so Queen C
choose the classical variation more subs
from I'm in some money what is this so
many subs so many more subs maybe I'm
insane money's confused the goal is not
to reach 10,000 subs on Twitch just yet
the goal is to reach 10,000 subs on
YouTube but examine some money
there's too many complicated names to
try and read off but welcome to all of
you new people Knights f3 so this is
basically our goes in with Queen c2
which I'm trying to figure out what the
difference is
I assume c5 is a very playable move
probably castling is the most principled
move let's just castle
this principle chess
I'm very soon I would probably like to
play c5 96 this is very common idea when
the Queen commits early to see to where
d4 is slightly less defended and
sometimes the Queen is even a target on
c2 and Bishop g5 is reasonable now I'm
thinking c5 and if he takes and d4 good
throw in h6 I'm gonna throw in h6
because there's times where if he plays
Bishop h4 at some point I might want to
throw in g5 mm and this I'm happy about
this bishop pair which I might not keep
for long it's hoping to like just save
the bishop pair for later Bishop g6 runs
into c5 or Knight b5 so maybe I should
just take on c3
and how do I follow up Bishop takes c3
Queen takes c3 c5 d takes e5 Queen takes
c3 looks nice Bishop takes c3 Queen
takes c3 c5 you can take on d5 if I take
back it takes with Queen that's some
sort of like gambit maybe Knight knight
c6 there's also a line where I just take
on c3 I take on c4 and then play Bishop
b7 or play b6 and then there should be
seven or Bishop a6 let's go for that
se7 is falling
yeah this is a line I just not entirely
familiar with okay so see five is a
candidate move taking on c4 as a
candidate move c6 is kind of ugly move
which I don't really want to play 96 is
probably too crazy
hmm
so I'm calculating a line D takes e4
Queen takes e4 b6 Queen takes e7 and
then trying to figure out if there's
compensation there like Bishop a6
followed by rook c8 but he is Queen e5
in Queen e7 and knight c6 let's go for
it
it's rapid chess I think it leads to a
position which should be easier for
block to play I would think just because
there's initiative and White has to
develop
and hello to more people in the chats
hello to pars 3 3 3 3 playpen Feingold
I've laid back vine gold a few times
online once in the tournament my score
against Ben is is not very good excuse
me in me like almost 100% of the time
and I'm not I'm not accepting any
congratulations yet until until we get
27 more subscribers spinal tap chess I'm
doing well
always doing well when there's tea in
front of me
if you guys can convince Ben to come on
me chess and challenge me that would be
cool but might be hard to do double-o
people act uh below thanks for the more
bits this is slightly surprising so he
plays e3 so maybe he's scared of going
into that line now I would like to play
some move like c5 was very typical move
in these structures if he takes I take
he takes and then like Knight a6 and I
wouldn't c5 and if Queen takes c4 I take
let's do this things look under control
this is very typical of nimzo-indian
like it's kind of a quiet position but
there's going to be some small
positional differences I will try and
exploit it make sense to take right away
unless I want to play like 97
in 97 is very possible
yeah let's play 97 first there's no
reason to take because if he ever takes
or pushes I take on c3 and damage the
structure for white and I might want to
leave the tension further like I might
just want to play me 6 Bishop e7 and
just continue applying pressure
whenever there's pawn tension and it's
not good for your opponent to capture
your pawn then sometimes you don't want
to capture their con just make them
think a bit more every move
I would go to chess calm and play him
but I've already like mentioned elitist
or in the title of the stream and it's
too much of a hassle just to like change
the title and then switch the stream
layout it's possible but too much work
but at some point I'll probably probably
experiment I want to get into YouTube
live streaming which I know be a bit
different than twitch but I'm open to
using other platforms okay let's play b6
hello - just add blue just add blue I
was looking for you like the last couple
of days tell me he fixed my settings
well let me know when you're gonna be
around the next like 10 yeah the next 10
days in a row I'm gonna be a the st.
Louis Chess Club every single day and
starting Wednesday I'll be doing
commentary for their their Fall Classic
event so that's gonna take up most of my
time so this could actually be one of my
last streams in a while if that takes up
too much of my time okay if I take on g4
because I want to play Knight c5 Bishop
e5 is a good move
taking on g4
maybe rook t8 firsts preparing Bishop e7
38 yeah let's play trip to Utes keeping
a lot of tension
yeah tomorrow around five ish is perfect
I am onerous with uh some gifted by
toilet noggin welcome i io non dress did
not see him in the chat but maybe he's
hanging around somewhere
so this is a ten plus five game we we
both use just about half our time the
first 13 moves so pretty quickly it's
gonna turn into some sort of blitz chess
but at least I know my plan like the
plan is Bishop e7 rook c8 build up
pressure if necessary I can take on d4
there's a line where he can take on d7 I
take back he takes on c5 and we
basically trade everything and get a
symmetrical structure but he's not going
into that so now I think I can do this
now I'm hitting f3 now he takes on g7
interesting I have to take back or can I
take on f3 first Bishop take f3 pawn
take f3 oh he can also move his bishop
back wait okay so bishops I got three
pawn to got three rook take t7 he takes
on c5 I take on do you one then take on
c6 and hit the rook number wise Bishop
take f3 he moves the bishop back to b5
now his work is hanging I think this is
quite strong I think he may be
overlooked this move too cuz now
yeah his pawn structure is just gonna be
shattered I mean he has to take and then
I take back and f3 is a target
I mean maybe he'll go into this line
where like he takes on c5 when I take
and hit the rook yeah let's do this
first
he can't take on that six cuz I take on
that phone with Chuck which okay which
is very kind of him it's intermedia
moves
in between loose they're easy to miss
there are a couple in between moves
they're the first in between moves
Bishop Sega three and then the second in
between was rook takeoff one White had
to take on d1
and then I was planning to take on a
three hitting the rook and then there's
some threat of rook c8 it could get
weird like you could play so you could
play like rook c1 and rook c8 before I
think black is like has slightly better
chances cuz White's King is so exposed
but it would be a fight and take work to
win this I'd probably like take and put
the work on c6 and then start pushing
the H pawn but that was a nice gift for
my opponents you got yelled at by on us
for the last hour I've seen some of on
dresses like YouTube videos where he
gives lessons with students and that's
one thing I admire about him like just
like being very firm with students which
I just I can't I can't yell at students
at least not in the way that he does it
but yeah a kudos to Honduras I mean
that's probably one of the best ways
people can learn okay let's get a new
game I have to play Amun Somani he gave
so many subs no random number this time
look I'm in some money what am I
expecting he's gonna play a London he's
gonna play before he's gonna play a
London what do I want to play have fun
you play a Dutch let's play a Dutch see
what happens I haven't played the Dutch
in a while
lady six will play like a Leningrad
setup which is supposed to be pretty
effective against the London especially
when the bishops on d3 so he's just
playing automatically because now the
idea is to eventually play e5 let's
start with 97 or Queenie eighths let's
start with Queenie aids
I have to be careful of like these light
squares like Queen B 3 check could be a
little bit annoying but not too annoying
so Bishop g5 escaping the potential idea
of e5e 4 first move that comes to mind
is ninety four and if he takes takes
Knight FD - I could play d5 there which
looks nice
hmm
I remember last time I played him we got
into like a ridiculous and game where he
was better but he wasn't playing for a
win so I was playing for a win and then
at some point he offered the draw but
instead of offering a draw he clicked
the resign button and the game just
ended with me winning such a great
finish
so hopefully this time will be slightly
more calming and less crazy but we'll
see I just realized some idea that if he
does take on e4 and plays a 92 I have
this kind of interesting move Queen b5
hitting the bishop and hitting the b2
pawn okay so he plays Bishop h4
let's go for this
just want to reinforce the Knights and I
might even like get some stone wall
structure I'll first play AE 6 here and
then very soon d 5 H 6 g 5 stuff is
happening
Dutch is like a mirror Sicilian it's a
completely different opening it's maybe
some ideas of it attacking the center
from this side but because like black
opens up the King it's a bit different I
guess say Sicilian is much more sound
than Dutch
okay now d5 looks nice because e4 is
very well reinforced I don't think he
ever wants to take because a pawn on e4
is quite troublesome for whites also
troublesome is this threat so if he
plays Bishop g3 I would just take it and
then his pawn structure is a little bit
shattered I also have ideas with be 65
and then c4 so I feel like this position
is just about pushing pawns for the next
several moves let's play c6 keeping
things defended
the one piece set is really depressed is
this Bishop but that's okay I'll give it
some antidepressants at some points and
it'll be happy in the future but okay
now g5 is the real threats if he takes
some d5 I probably take with this pawn I
would have to maybe watch out for this
pin but it's not not a problem
immediately and the thing for a white
like he doesn't necessarily want a
Castle kingside because that's where I'm
attacking but where else does a king go
at some point the center might open up
I'm imagining like the long-term plan
for this Bishop is g5 9 f6 Queeny 7 and
then maneuvering it to h5 where maybe
it'll be happier hello - holla vard hf
good to see you
g4 unexpected but this is a good move
because this is slightly more loose
if I play g5
there's some crazy variation like g5
Bishop here I play maybe I start with f4
he takes I take on D - he takes I take
on d4 there's so many things to consider
here because I have this capture I have
this capture I have this capture I have
this move I have potential for this so
what to do
g5 bishop g3 first inclination is to
take and maybe play Knight here and go
into e4 again there's another cool idea
which I'm actually fathoming
is to play b5 see take b5 + c5
threatening c4 and he takes here then I
take here so it's someone of a pawn
sacrifice I guess he could take on now
he could take on d5 so that doesn't work
another option is just to try and leave
all the tension think everywhere which
could be reasonable
actually wait no I'm seeing a four seam
line okay so g5 bishop g3 night take d2
first he takes with the king then his
knight on f3 is undefended if he takes
with Knight
then I have f4 he takes here and then I
take on d4 and that's just a mess or
maybe no I don't take on d4 first I take
on that floor hit the bishop and then
take on d4 let's go for that because I
think it's winning a pawn so was a move
order again I take no I play f4 first no
I take first and then playoff for
I feel like at the end of these lines as
king should be less safe than my king
because the center should be opening up
in my favor the only thing is this
bishops kind of scary but it's just a
bishop what's the best line going
against French defense I really like to
play the two Knights attack so you don't
play d4 but you play Knight f3 and
Knight c3 so Bishop h2 so maybe I'm not
winning upon but as bishops shutout miss
Bishop is just as sad as this Bishop
I have a weird idea probably not good
though hmm I'm gonna play just a natural
move Queen f7 very direct threats have
to move quicker to there's no increments
what didn't just add blew in yeah I win
not sure what that means yeah now I'm
thinking e5 cuz d5 is reinforced an e5
it's just okay now it's time to push
pawns
maybe e4 is coming and this is coming
and if he takes and I'll take with
Knights yeah Queen f7 was a nice move I
think because it had the the
multi-purpose of this in this
while work c7 but what's the threats
whenever they play a scary move always
have to ask yourself what's the threats
know if there's an immediate threat I
mean I could take here yeah let's just
take their time is important informative
books on positional chess lately not
lately unfortunately and there's a few
books that come to mind positional play
by a garnet is very good also reassess
your chess is a great book also there's
a book I was recommended actually not
too long ago which I haven't taken a
look at yet it's called the positional
chess handbook by golfer I believe
either golfer or Geller which I heard is
really good call Mongoose a good time to
catch me live if you want to play a game
send me a challenge the problem if I
took F take e3 his rook is defended by
the Knights so you would have some
discovered attack it's a little bit
annoying my Knights pinned ok would
really like to play one of these moves
at some point
and now we're entering very strange
territory I feel kind of stuck I think
I'll start with v6 a sneaky idea which
involves controlling the square
Queeny six it's hard to stop there's
also some idea like if he plays king d2
here then I can play Knight c5 and it's
a clever tactic another another case of
the intermediate move I take as Queen
and then win the exchange
so it's a strange position like this
bishop stock that rook is stuck King is
kind of stuck in the center
Samsonite is in the chats just got home
from work at first I read that as just
got homework I felt bad for you but now
I feel good for you I grasp of line
against D for Budapest gambits if they
play c4 and move to if they don't play
c4 and move to they're probably gonna
play at London and then there's ways to
be aggressive against that too so the
idea with b6 is to play queenie 695
which i think i can go ahead and play
when my knight comes to c5 there's
threats of taking the Queen there's
ideas of 94
there's ideas of trapping this rook
Queen D Sixtus traps a rook I believe no
rook c6 okay maybe Queenie for I'd be
fun
Queenie for if he takes I just have a
massive wall of pawns Wow and all of the
pawns are defended this defends assist
defends us maybe Bishop e6 no Bishop e6
is problematic for whites because now if
he takes I take and then his rook is
hanging and the knight is hanging but
maybe he's surviving somehow
yeah there's also Kings Indian defense
which is I mean it's quite aggressive
but you have to kind of understand the
middlegame plans
I did not see rook takes e5 but now I
see it let's have some fun or is that
too much fun
no this okay this is too much fun the
four pawns in the center he has two
pieces for a rook I think I should play
King h8 first I feel like last time we
played it was the same material in
balance I play this if he plays Bishop
f5 I'm sacking objectively black is
worse but objectively black is having
more fun or is that subjectively it
doesn't matter I won Connect four this
is the most beautiful connect for it to
like on the on the fifth rank maybe the
third or second rank would be more
beautiful
while he's sacking back he wants to win
d4 well there goes my Connect four
I've played Bishop here I get forts kind
of but I can pin and I'm winning the
Knights Supreme of this actually let's
not people of that there might be some
cases where I I torture this let's take
it and I can take here and then I could
cut the King suit izuta interesting name
thanks for the sub
and Johanna in the chat hello Joanna
good to see you back so I went from
being down material to being up a bishop
for a pawn this King is being cowardly
on a3 let's just run the King in and the
goal is to mate or win his rook or both
hmm
I play a5 preparing Bishop b4 okay let's
play this that's annoying
okay Bishop comes to be for the rook
takes on 83 yeah interesting game I mean
white was better at some point towards
the end until I pins the Knights I mean
it's a really fascinating position
actually so I'm not sure what's going on
here like White's up a knight for a pawn
but I mean the problem for whites I
don't think he can take here cuz rook be
one king e2 and then I meet somehow okay
if d3 is good enough and then I win the
rook so this is probably full
compensation somehow
anyway that was fun there's a youtube
command too I believe if you type an
exclamation point YouTube it should take
you to the the channel 21 more subs it's
gonna happen soon maybe 169 subs on on
Twitch it's also nice ok let's play
someone else give me a random number
between 1 and 12 8 okay
uno dos tres Quatro Cinco seis siete
Ocho ok playing this person rated 1360
good luck this is person here
okay this is I was gonna tell Syria to
set a timer for 10 seconds but we have a
game I think the goal will be to play as
aggressively as possible yeah we're
gonna play the Stafford gambit
I'm actually in the process of recording
a course on like a whole repertory
against one e4 which should be released
by the end of the month and this is kind
of the main starting position double
Opie block double O what's your leach s
name I don't usually take bribes but let
me know your name
what does CCI see see see I see I think
you mean you mean st. Louis chess club
probably yeah if you guys want to see
YouTube content you should not go to my
channel at least for recent content so
I'm doing videos for st. Louis he's a
couple of weeks Bishop c4 is a blunder
I'm trying to remember the best way to
punish it I think just Knight g4
immediately is just crushing this is one
of the many traps y can fall into the
funny thing about Bishop c4 there's
multiple ways to punish it like those
bishop take f2 there might even be Queen
d4 immediately now the problem for like
there's no great way to defend f2 the
only way is to castle which I'm
expecting and then we'll then we'll see
what happens this will be one of the
lines I cover and in the course yeah so
I think the abbreviation for st. Louis
chess club now is SLCC just st. Louis
chess club it used to be chess club in
school and scholastic center of st.
Louis but that was clearly too difficult
to say so I think they've just
simplified things
yeah after castling Queen h4 is just
brutal because these two pawns are now
attached I have to choose attack three
times
h2s attacked two times and both pawns
are not sufficiently defended so black
is guaranteed to win something at some
point
yeah the most recent video I did for st.
Louis was Bishop take f7 I'm actually
debating not to take the bishop because
you also play Queen f3 check and then
Queen g3 I mean I'll be up a piece but
what if I play King d8 let's have some
fun
I think King d8 might objectively be the
best move to I mean I might be missing
something but this looks pretty good
that Chrisette thanks for watching
you're gonna watch TV you can watch me
on TV just like chromecast but maybe the
wife would objects I don't know
team Carlsen our team Caruana I got a
text today from a friend asking if I'm
on like Cara Juana's team which I'm not
but now I'm rooting for Cara wanna but
I'll be in London during the match it
should be fun to watch my takeoff -
looks pretty crushing
if rook take off to win the exchange and
the mare will be bishop take each three
ideas and the fact that he took on f7 is
actually helpful because I have ideas of
rook f8 and using my rook for some
attack I'm also threatening like maiden
three here like the threat is something
like 19 h3 wait he didn't defend against
a threat and I take h3 is double check
and then then I just moved back to F 2
with discovered check and then I'll play
Queen h1 and end with mates
I guess there's one way to prolong it
but that's ok y d8 over f8 because I was
scared that like when I take on f2 there
D consequences on the open F file
well I've won so many games in this
fashion like this um this position after
Knight g4 after this game finishes I'll
take a look I'm on me chest but I think
it's one of the the quickest ways to
like to beat an amateur player in less
than 15 moves and I say one of the
quickest ways one of the most common
wastes because white essentially played
natural moves and then just gets
punished had to be a lot more careful
and in this position white has to be
incredibly careful not an easy position
no it's made into its double check and
then Queen each one is meats
okay well that was nice 12 moves um why
don't you play this way as white what
does that mean because I don't like
losing 12 moves as white if he's
referring to this game to address the
other question I'm like I'm happy to
play on Jeff's comm recently I've been
having lag issues because my stream is
just it takes up so much CPU usage I
just haven't been able to stream the
arena kings tournaments because if
there's too much lag um so I'm gonna get
help tomorrow from from someone and
hopefully it'll be better but let's take
a look at night g4 yeah black is scoring
amazingly Oh Queen a threesome move
about Queen f3 we're now three is a good
move
okay I'm out of tea bishop take f2 or
castling wait does my g4 the best move
yeah 94 Queen f3 ah 95 hey it's another
sub Sara Nino Sara Neely oh thanks for
the sub this looks nice there's a funny
line if okay the only move for a why
this stuff like we need to to defend the
Queen and the bishop and then I mean the
flock wants to I can take on f2 at Queen
tag f2 Knight takes e4 and if King take
f2 I have Queen D for both lines I win
the bishop okay new new victim give me a
random number between 1 and 10 I was
weird give me a random number between 1
and 10
800 chill again I'll try vase okay 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 sky monkey sky money wait no not
Skype I don't know okay I'm playing
coffin Mongoose I thought I I thought it
was Skype monkey or money but maybe I
was wrong okay so let's let's play a
game
I'm sorry to whoever was number 8 but
it's too late now
oh if someone was asking what to play
against French defense earlier and this
is one of my favorite lines maybe you
look into using your video card for the
video compression and so CPU what does
that even mean and how do I do that
I have a MacBook Pro it's 2015
a 92 is leads to a very pleasant
structure for white the idea is Nigeria
ship somewhere d3 Castle black will have
more space but white will have good
piece placements double o P black you
forgot to tell me your username or I
just missed it in the chat but let me
know your knee chest username toilet
noggin is off to bed you're gonna miss
the epic celebration I don't know even
what I'm gonna do
could do some dance or some partying
ghs k good to see you thanks for
watching usually when black plays a six
a four is just a natural reaction to
stop B 5 then the bishop will come to
see for still I just want a complete
development Opie black okay
I'm looking oh the third challenge okay
let's play g3 first yeah goodnight to
toilet noggin thanks for being useful
maybe I can take or maybe I leave it
there and I end up taking no let's take
first this is actually very useful
because now I have that for hitting the
bishop with tempo
black black has one piece developed and
I'm ready to Castle and start breaking
through at f5 or maybe 9 h5 or Queen g4
or just a combination of all of these
moves let's start with castling angelic
Jake welcome back
this is looking very nice the play queen
g4 maybe tempt him to castle
my name is Joey thanks for the sub I'm
very tempted to play f5 but I'm not sure
if it's sound or unsound
I also attempted to play e5 94 and then
Knight f6 check that gives away squares
I think I'll play Queen h4 first so
flexible move may be preparing this or
maybe just preparing this making sure my
queen is not not targeted what does
subscribing do so it gives you access to
emotes it takes away ads so you don't
have to watch ads before the stream
starts I believe and it supports the
channel so it leads to more more streams
and more videos and also chances to play
me which I I do random people sometimes
but maybe I should do more like sub
challenges but I like the nature of
randomness h5 well Queen f6 looks
enticing I'll play f5 first I just want
to loosen the pawns if he takes this way
than my bishops happy ok my bishop is
happy and then Queen f6 hitting the rook
hitting the pawn rook f8 then I have
just the last straw which should break
the mongooses back the call mongoose is
back but it won't be so column I thought
if it's back is breaking oh I didn't see
rook h7 though
yeah bro cage seven is a good move hmm
Bishop Bishop take f7 probably doesn't
work Knight take no let's just play
Bishop g5 I just want to like add all my
pieces into the play and then the fact
that all my pieces are doing stuff
directed that blacks position should be
good enough without needing to
calculates anything like to forcing
hello znation chess thanks for watching
also thanks for the comment you wrote a
long comment my name is Joey but I'm
trying to read it now I'm getting
distracted by other comments scrolling
up when you do post game analysis how
many mistakes blunders and accuracies do
I usually make in longer games
I usually don't check my like the stock
fish results after games maybe that
would be interesting I mean my games are
are available to check I I would think
maybe a couple mistakes couple
inaccuracies per game I know I've had
some games that have been like perfect
according to the engine but most games
will have some issues okay so my g8
I really don't want to trade Queens so
I'm calculating this line with Bishop
take a seven rook take f7 queen tg6
where I'm attacking the knight and I'm
attacking the queen that looks amazing I
think that's just crushing
yeah thanks so much my name is Joey
appreciate the kind words it's comments
like that which are actually route like
really motivating which I really
appreciate I'm sad to say like I get
them like I get them in YouTube comments
and like direct messages and sometimes
it's hard to reply to them all but but
yeah thank you
let's take a wait if I take on gar cafe
it's things are good
because Queen age 7 this is gonna hang
my blocking is so exposed now I do
apologize for the lag it's probably
caused by just enormous ly large
subscriber number what to do
Bishop g5 let's take on H 5 first and
then maybe Bishop f4 oh he's about to
flag - let's do this I want to open the
e-file so I'll probably take on got 5
and then he'll flag yeah
tough game that's a fun line to play
against the French it's some nice
coordination
I don't think 95 is a good move just
breaks an opening principle like moving
the same piece twice that's the piece
that's already like on the good square
so Lux should probably play a move like
97 maybe like this and this and this I
can't take my face off the screen
because then Johanna will get upset but
I'm gonna get a session tomorrow as
someone that will hopefully help me fix
whatever lag there is let's play someone
new give me a random number between 1
and 15 ok
oh we're gonna play this guy first cuz
he kept throwing bits
hey he's 908 I didn't played someone
below a thousand in a long time Wow okay
we're over an hour into the stream
eighteen subs away the stream is not
ending until we break 10,000 which maybe
it wasn't the best thing to say there
so I want to encourage people to
subscribe okay we have another French
Wow let's do this how many bits to get a
game yet to be determined it continually
changes depending on supply and demand
I guess knight c6 is an interesting move
I think the move to play here is just
developing my name is Joey want some
game oh man I don't encourage people to
make multiple accounts because usually
if YouTube will eventually delete them
let's take care and then castle I've
completed development at least with
knights and casting before black has
developed anything
okay t4 looks attractive
always nice when you can play a proving
move and kick the opponent in the way
question is still how I'm gonna break
through and I'm thinking 95 will be a
nice nice way to keep initiative because
this is a target for pits from messy
Marvin J's something-something Joe
really have to find that way no cancel I
think also I get lag because of all the
pending challenges too it's just too
many too many things going on please
don't unsub and be so mean okay so c6 is
hanging I have a sneaky trick which
probably doesn't work I wanted to play
queen h5 but then Bishop take d4 just
take on c6 free pawn
and now d5s attacked I take a pawn
attack another pawn if you take Sonia
for I attack as Queen all about
initiative
let's take on d5 if the e-file opens
then there's a clear pathway to the king
Oh Evan gave its - I was distracted by
messy Marvin thanks Evan what do I do
I could take on e7
I mean I'm up to pawns life is so great
I can play 94 first 94 queen g6 might
take you seven Queens Aggie four mmm I
don't know let's just take on you
southern then maybe next I'll play like
tricky one maybe I'll take on e6 next
okay we'll see what happens call a
bracer zero double - wait a minute what
oh he took a pawn but he didn't take the
knight which means I can take the Queen
and then save the night and then be up a
piece and a pond that's nice what are my
thoughts in general about the past
Olympian my thoughts I'm like honestly
I'm really kind of jealous and I have a
lot of like FOMO that I wasn't there
because I've never attended an Olympian
and that's like high on my bucket list
of like a chess event to attend like the
photos and videos I saw were just
incredible I mean I could talk about
like the actual chess itself and the
results but just the nature of like
people from every single country in the
world competing in chess was was really
cool just to see virtually sure it was
much cooler to actually see in person so
I'm hoping to go for the next one I
think the next one is in Russia
I can't Iman Sisk FOMO is fear of
missing outs which I feel like I had a
lot of buts
if I were to go to the next one I would
either go as like a reporter journalist
photographer for someone or or maybe
even a coach for some like lesser
privileged country I just need
connections if anyone's watching and
you're from like some random country
that needs someone to coach their
Olympiad team let me know so it would be
cool so I think there's a lot of teams
like in Africa who go who don't get that
much support
I know Maurice Ashley was coaching I
want to say Madagascar it's pretty
interesting gig what do I do
let's play rock do you want to bring
more pieces into action there's a
potential meeting idea involving this
this this and then checkmate is Bishop
h6 so let's start that and see what
happens
okay
it just takes two more steps to mate
well now it's difficult because he wants
to take the night let's play this
okay this is really sneaky so I'm
letting him win a piece
he could take take and then take I'm
hoping for that you'll also take and
then I just take here shouldn't be nice
and then King g7 rook GA maids Keaney 7
hmm
let's repeats double check
[Music]
I mean there's so many ways to win I'm
just trying to meet before he Flags
maybe ok 9 of 6 will come next
ok I'll take with rook
yeah a tough game that's what happens
sometimes when white so quick to develop
I feel like a six was already maybe the
first mistake was just development was
in White's favor anyway that's even
perfect with more bits wait I wanted to
play through their own the play and
double Opie yeah thanks for playing and
thanks for watching and thanks for the
pits I'm gonna play this guy J something
something Joe because I think this is
Joey I played them before okay that's
what you for yeah I want to play
everyone but it's not quite possible
let's play a wing cabinets haven't
played this in a while
a slightly fun opening
make him think on move - he's moving the
stream so I can be as transparent as I
want I mean the wane gamut isn't like a
sound opening except someone played it
in some big tournament I think Kamsky
played it against someone at US
Championships one year and the game
edited in like a draw or something I
think I can take here the whole point of
this gambit is that okay there's a half
of an a file and one of these pieces can
come to a3 ooh b5 looks very attractive
because now the Knights attacked and
there's a pin mmm
black should probably be regretting not
taking the pawn when he had the chance
it's a knight can't take on on d5
because I'm I played Bishop take b5
though only say I swear for the knight
is a six but then I play d4 I'm just
gonna keep having fun arrghh getting
crushed this is bad says my opponent
that's a good sign
still take some work maybe they can play
Queen a4 looks like an interesting move
it might be like just not the most
accurate move but it looks like the most
fun move there's a 30 second delay maybe
refresh your page because it's possible
like you pause at some points there
should be more of a like 10 second or 5
second delay Bishop g7 I assumed I can
take here with another pawn wait no that
was the first pawn I won so I'm up upon
and now I went a knight okay now this is
crushing the wing gambit
so much success kind of feel bad for my
opponents but at the same time kind of
not and it's a weird scenario because my
pawn might be pawns pinned but his a
pawns pinned and they're both attacking
each other
okay so g6 he wants to play Bishop g7
and castle and that was actually the fun
that rook enough times have a really
crazy idea to take on a six
he takes here then I take here is it
worth it having a pawn that far probably
not
what's his rating it's casual yeah let's
not do that
too risky it's like Queen a5 being a bit
more patience
be six
now I'm thinking of a really cool
variation I don't know if it works I
want it to work involves sacking a queen
for a bishop or queen for two bishops
hmm it's so tempting
thinking about like Queen a3 queen bee
for allowing a five and then taking here
and then I lose my queen and then I take
on that seven Keeney seven I take the
bishop it's just probably bad looks like
we need to the goal is to play Queen e2
and then Knight f3 and then castle and
just be happy yeah I know what Shia
LeBeouf would say but I don't get
motivated by him too easily okay now I'm
gonna play Queen e2 and now I have
massive attack against this a6 pond
which is no longer pinned but okay I'm
gonna take it and now white is up two
pawns it's complete development oh he
wants to win this pawn let's play f3 Wow
okay well this one's still attacked
the spawns defended there's a funny idea
to play a seven and Bishop b8
I think that I can do this rook is just
kind of stuck on AIDS this might be
over-the-top but okay it's a fun
position I have to move much quicker
because there's no increment he's
preventing Bishop Yates let's play nine
h3
yeah I think blacks should have taken
this pawn when he had the chance because
now the pieces are like there's no peace
beyond the set drink everything's
restricted that's complete developments
yeah my opponents said that he's muted
the stream so he's not I don't think
he's hearing me talk
I'm PlayBook here or I could just take
the pawn immediately yeah that's a free
pod now so many free things another free
pond and both of these are hanging but
I'm attacking the knight this is
defended this is defended so let's take
the Knights
okay he wins back he can actually win
back two pawns unfortunately that's one
of my most valuable possessions is a
7-point was that him okay that wasn't an
asset so you should have played Rick
take a seven there I think now I can
play oh he wants to take this rook
that's why tonight see for first the
Queen's almost trapped Queen has c5 or
d8 or f6 if Queen c5 I have Bishop to d6
if Queen f6 whoa okay let's take this
and take this and take this and then
take this and time up a rook a bishop a
knight and two pawns
pre move this that was a series of
trades but I think they were beneficial
trades for me if you want to improve
your positional chess start by looking
at Karpov games car club games are the
best see he plays so simple just look at
Karpov games where he wins this black
and most of them are just like really
nice positional wins and if you want to
like be engaging look at Karpov games
where you're you're trying to guess each
move he place it's a good training
exercise good game that was a fun game
the wing and it's never disappoints okay
uh who do we play next okay I'll give
messy Marvin a game because he was being
nice
good luck messy Marvin
this is gonna be a London I feel like
this is gonna be a London this is coming
ooh okay it came what do I do
I want to play something crazy Oh what
can i play that's crazy let's play c6 I
have an idea of sacking a pond let's see
if he takes us I'll admit I've like I've
never seen this before I just came up
with this on the spot
I don't think it's great I was really
hoping he would take so I could play
Queen a5 and win the bishop yes this is
also possible I'll play this get some
imbalance position well maybe I'll chop
his Bishop Knight here I'll just keep
the initiative for as long as possible
attack the b-pawn
Queen z1 okay the goal is to play C 5
and put maximum pressure on this so I
can eventually get through to this start
with Bishop f5 on c5 Knight c6 is a
major idea a lot more one-sided than the
last game
wait you won the first game Wow
I even realized that so that was my
revenge makes me feel good
hello ginger 64 good to see you welcome
back I just drop a piece no I did not
cuz I have to smooth defending the
bishop checking the King and essentially
unpinning the Knights now this is
interesting because I could I can't take
on c3 because wait maybe I can't take on
c3 I take c3 no time to calculate let's
just play it because this is undefended
he takes with Queen I take his Queen and
then take the bishop if he takes my
bishop I take his knights and then take
his Bishop confusing position I think
it's working out well
so this is a new response to the London
c6 combined with g5 let's move back
let's move back mmm let's attack the
goal is to someday get some nice mating
pattern with this Bishop piercing
through and the knight delivering mates
how do I manage that sakip on
I just wanted this diagonal to open up
so now his king is stuck and all it will
take is one check to deliver meats it's
still easier said than done
but it's within reach this bishop is so
strong really nothing can challenge it
or maybe something can yeah it's a good
move
let's save the bishop
it's another good news he's 20 seconds
left
okay I'm gonna go completely insane and
give away my queen or my or my Paulo 97
but this is now mate
there we go it's funny I'm leaving all
of my pieces available to be captured
you can take the Queen take the pawn and
then he can take the bishop or the rook
I think it would have been best for him
to take the pawn and then the rook or
then the bishop I don't know
rook see it was a fun movie though I'm
not sure what's going on there like
final position cuz might take e7 King h8
I take a five the whole plan like if a
knight take out five it's to take on a
two guess he has king c2 and whites
probably actually much better here I
would think let's just check ya whites
crushing because blacks attack runs at
my average sent to pawn loss was 212 oh
man if people can see that or 178 oh
it's going down because it starts at the
end and then works its way backward okay
yeah there was a lot of questionable
moves that game but uh this line with c6
is actually really interesting because
III g5 I think it's playable Bishop to
g5 Queen 85 which I assume messy Marvin
saw but then if I mean what happened was
kind of Pleasant and then if Bishop g3
h5 it's also interesting okay
new opponent let's play sky money
because I called him sky monkey before
and I felt that about it so it's a 5 + 3
game sent upon its easiest if you just
google it like Google sent to pawn me
chess org will give you a pretty good
explanation
essentially the higher the sent the
higher the sent upon the loss the worse
you played okay let's play e5 and then
I'm having to go for this one back to
the good old Stafford gambit
I'm 13 subs away if there's people
watching who are not subscribed to me on
YouTube it's free to subscribe on
YouTube unlike twitch okay I'm just
gonna copy him until it makes sense not
to copy him
yeah III I think is helpful to me
because my bishop wants to actually be
here on this diagonal Bishop III play
Bishop e6
it's going to be a slightly symmetrical
position zoo desert
thanks for the 200 bits if you want a
game let me know your username 97 is
such a typical maneuver like 97 96 this
is usually the way you can start playing
for a win where now the plan is to
continually attack with all the pieces
and he's slightly slower to attack or to
bring his Knights because now g3 is
covered problem is I can't play Queen f6
right away cuz then he trots the Queen
but okay now now this is a different
story
[Music]
so 9f for let's play Knight f4 and I
still want to play Queen f6 and just
build up pressure sometimes even c65
could be useful I don't have many chess
sets that's true I do most mostly online
chess and when I play in tournaments
like the tournaments I play and they
provide chess sets so there's really no
reason to have a chess it's kind of sad
to say but I'll play a lot over the
board like when I'm in st. Louis I mean
st. Louis chess club has sets all over
all over the place and they have
tournaments all over the place knife f4
I mean taking on each three might not
even be a sacrifice it can very well
imagine he'll play Queen d2 here and
then I take h3 just wins upon I don't
know if there's any immediate threat
that's a good sign super defensive I
think 9h four is just crushing because
g2 can't really be defended it's just
like mush of pieces in the corner it
looks safe but okay usually this isn't
the safest setup he does that move and
if I
let's play this maybe I'm not winning
the the Jeep on okay I'm threatening
Nate's
threatening the pawn couple no I'm
threatening the pawn three times so
there's really only one move for a white
in this position
ooh I was expecting night take f4 it's
not some nother move looking for a fancy
night mates maybe they don't exist let's
take and then I'll take on h4 so I've
won upon and then Knight f4 will come 10
subs away the countdown begins
yeah h3 is the targets I'm gonna play
like Knight f4 that should be good
enough I guess
Queen f3 I still have to think four not
three maybe g5 g 4 okay f4 is a free
pawn also allows Queen g3 it's like when
g3 first
and then I just want to meet ok let's
take on that for
and let's take here so now I'm just up a
bunch of material and you shan't see no
chef's Club will let you post lectures
you've had there on my channel I mean
when when I do lectures for them there's
like a staff member who records and edit
some so it's meant to be on their
channel I could potentially do like
there are some lectures that aren't
recorded if I recorded them myself I'm
sure that would not be a problem maybe
be good pretty good cross-promotion but
I don't know I mean I feel like any
Content I do during lectures should be
on their channel just for a good
practice
now I mentioned this earlier but for
anyone new watching the next okay
starting Wednesday there's gonna be
commentary every day so I'll be I'll be
in the studio I'll be in a studio be
wheres fiddler was just a few just a
couple months ago and that'll be
interesting
can i play Queen h4 let's just take
another Brooke I'm up to exchanges and a
bunch of pawns and this rook lift is
probably going to be pretty devastating
I think yeah I think he's over also
thanks for the sub appreciate that I
don't know how to pronounce your name
but thanks anyway
rook h5 is coming rogue h5 is now forced
mate I'll be doing commentary for the
Fall Classic it's a series of GM level
tournaments I actually do commentary for
the summer class of 2 which is held back
in me yeah this is kind of a typical
structure like usually the ideas are our
knight c6 9 h5 Queen f6 everything kind
of came to life nicely good game sky
money okay
new opponents give me a random number
between 1 and 17 ok 1 2 3 there's so
much lag with counting 4 or 5 6 7 8 9 ok
I don't know there we go
good luck I don't know six away so
exciting it could happen in this game
pretty Willis I don't know why your
comment got blocked are you asking about
private jet lessons
although mothers keep weird um every
every private lesson I give is different
I don't usually follow a lesson plan I
usually adapt to where the students at
and like what their level is what their
tendencies are based on what games they
play I try and work with students based
on what they need to improve on am I
gonna stop when I hit 10,000 I don't
know probably gonna keep going
give me momentum
this is a classic classic trick it's a
center for a trick it's another thing
like so many newer players will kind of
walk into Bishop III unfortunately for
white does not win the pawn back just
okay lots of free stuff I think he
Castle because that's a chance to win in
one move like 94 looks so attractive
here but let's not lose maybe Queen f6
up a piece okay to trade Queens my
streams are so rare and I'll stream a
few times a week is that too rare for
you would you like it to be medium rare
or maybe medium let's play c6 I'm gonna
be so busy like this coming week that
I'm the sad to say yeah this could be
this could be the last one until like
next week but I might do like some mini
streams just like half hour here half
hour there
do you have any tips for stabilizing
chess results first I thought my pawn
was pinned but it's not pinned it's just
a free Queen he gets a check ok let's go
for some attack you either go 5 out of 6
or 1 out of 5 that's normal at a certain
level I mean it happens to everyone
where be in good form or be in bad form
I think in like in terms of preparation
for a tournament going into a tournament
you should just focus a lot on like your
physical and mental form so rather than
like cramming chess tactics or like
trying to memorize opening lines focus
on just getting sleep getting off social
media working out eating well in
combination of those things can actually
make a difference when you go into like
a long event ok let's go for the kill
I've replaced John worth all of you but
John Bartholomew is my favorite youtuber
and streamer well it's flattering to
hear but it should be nothing John
Bartholomew is just a legend I remember
I played John in Washington Square Park
New York City back in it was 2013 or
2014 and then we played one lifts game I
remember like playing him without
knowing his name and then he told me his
name and I like vaguely knew it from
like seeing him at tournaments buddy as
before he like started his YouTube
channel so it's pretty cool like looking
back on that moment just to play a
future celebrity okay this is me almost
next move he has a few spy checks
okay Gigi okay well um takeaways from
that game there's another like a forty
five game that's funny like before I
started a stream I was spending like an
hour or two like preparing like this
these online course materials and the
whole course is going to cover lawns
like this where where black will play a
key 45 and then there's so many tricks
to get an advantageous back early on so
usually if white falls for this one of
the best moves is Bishop take f7 the
other approach is to play Bishop d3 in
this position Bishop d3 might be the
best move anyway a new game so that was
not the final game give me a random
number between 1 and 17 ok guy debord
ok I'll play you for again let me know
in the chat like what you guys play
first move is white you play e4 and you
play d4 I'm curious what the breakdown
is because I usually like to play
openings that people play themselves
okay so now we have a Petrov I'm gonna
play the MacCachren gambit well he pre
moved king f7 so he's prepared this
could be bad because I'm not at all
prepared I'm pretty sure this is a move
right d4 is a move for a Bishop c4 check
I think d4 is a move because if my TIGI
for there's queen h5 King e7 and Queen
e2 I guess
I point inside in the chat I get this
all the time but it's good he's thinking
here so if even if he got so all the
time
he hasn't researched the best approach
Bishop g4 looks playable I'll play off
three or maybe d5 or Bishop c4 first if
he plays d5 I can take with the bishop
Bishop c4 first so I don't think d5
works and then if the King moves back to
like ei then I can play this and he
doesn't have Bishop e6
and usually this type of sacrifice is
just dubious to give away a piece for
two pawns but there's some interesting
compensation as white just has full
center with these two pawns especially
if I can play f3 and develop black will
be a bit restricted in d5 so I assume I
can just take this ah but there's Queen
285 and he wins a piece I forgot he wins
yeah he wins a bishop on d5 oh wait no
Queen take d5 I can take on g4 if he
takes I take I have three pawns for the
piece bishops 85 point 85 Quinte chief
for that's not good so if I play f3 here
takes take take on e4 oh now they have
Queen f3 followed by g5
let's go for this
Bishop c4 was kind of a slip-up I'm
trying to fix the situation
I don't think that's a good move because
I can take and then play e5 I mean maybe
it's playable he's winning some pawns
back then we're gonna get like a really
crazy position and both our kings are
gonna just be completely exposed and if
Queen take d4 I take on f6 his King is
probably a bit less safe than Viking
yeah now I can castle missed a chance to
take on d4 now I'm winning the Knights
so plus not take the knight too soon LC
wants to take on e5
take on b7
I'll be slightly tricky I'm gonna play
Bishop to f4 and if he moves a knight
that I played Bishop g5 hitting the king
and the Queen
so the knight is still essentially
pinned through x-ray vision so I want to
keep my pawn on e5 here as long as
possible and then soon okay Knight c3
become
I mean you could say that I'm playing
for tricks but I'm also playing to put
my pieces on good squares ok think
Bishop f4 was a very reasonable move it
goes blacks a bit stuck I don't know
what he's gonna do
do I have Queen g5 Queen d5 was a
candidate move Queen e6 is one thing
about this position I don't want to
trade Queens because this King is less
safe just gonna continue developing
Knight c3
I think east six is a massive threat or
soon to be a massive threat
cousin my rook can come in with check
not to make it work somehow super major
pain
welcome Wow okay this is not gonna end
well for black but why is it not going
to end well
there's a line me six I think Quinta
ghee six here here no this is should be
just about over
Queen d5 King e7
now I'll probably just rook e1 and then
Queen d5 oh this is fun
black is up a piece currently for a pawn
but doesn't really matter
rook e1 so there's what there's three
legal moves no there's four legal moves
if the King moves anywhere I have 256
check otherwise yeah Queen d5
black is still up at night and sometimes
material isn't too relevant if kingi
seven there's Bishop g5 mates and if
King f6 probably made into somewhere I
remain in three my opponent says roof
that this fell apart I was giving a
lecture the kids class at the st. Louis
chess club the other day I was showing
some opening variation there just some
normal moves and after every move like
the kids just started saying move had no
idea where is coming from I'm not sure
if the the audio like picked it up but
be interesting to see okay Gigi yeah
that was a fun opening kosarin gambits
black has to be very precise I know
there's a way to play this and the
quickest what the quickest way to figure
out how to play this as black is just to
use a masters database
ah c5 c5 looks like such a strange move
but if Fox scores 40 percent in masters
games it's probably a good move and then
if d take c5 knight c6 interesting so
black develops quickly and tears down
the center some things to keep in mind
for the the Petroff players out there ok
5 away give me a random number between 1
and 18 this is like the third time 8 has
been the number 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
Toth tokumei it's 15 34 so c5 is a
reputation ok interesting interesting
username I don't know what language that
is but welcome
okay come on guys
five more subscribers there has to be
someone watching who's not subscribed to
me on YouTube what's this guy's actual
reading okay let's play the Budapest
hoping by the end of this game
we'll reach will reach 10,000 also we
just got a donation from jpp wise wizard
thanks for the $10 came out of nowhere I
don't know if you're in the chat but
thanks so much
wait is that Tanner at that no that's
10th I thought this saw the zeroes there
got excited but it's very kind let's
play a reverse French no play efore and
then followed by like d5 and Bishop d6 I
guess
whoa I know what happened there but
we're we're one subscriber away I don't
know if I'll finish this game before we
hit 10,000 this is exciting so much
drama the night's attacks what's gonna
happen well who's gonna be the 10,000
subscriber I don't know if YouTube will
let me know that is there a way to find
out
keep keep going until 20,000 I don't
think so
be here for a while unless whoever was
in the chat making so many new accounts
hey we hit 10,000 and - I just shot up
like three subscribers I guess so many
people wanted to be the 10,000 well I
don't have any champagne I don't have
any balloons or like loud music I'm
stuck playing this game but okay that's
a nice life milestone how do you
subscribe well it's too late now
I mean mission has already been
accomplished but if you want to
subscribe you can go to the youtube
channel just youtube.com / Rosen chess
or just just find the link in the chat
and yeah thanks guys I'm very grateful
like I've I honestly did not intend I
didn't have like a conscious moment that
I was gonna start a YouTube channel I
just had an account because I wanted to
reply to people on the st. Louis Chess
Club comments of my lectures and the
reason I started with people who are
subscribing to me and I wasn't making
videos and then at some point I just
started playing the streams up and now
it's a nice community of people let's
play let's play this a sack up on
if he takes all probably maybe I'll sack
two pawns and then give him for center
pawns which would be a false sense of
confidence and then I'll play Knight g4
and go for some kind of kill y'all start
with Bishop d6 so I don't know favorite
thing about Saint Louis about st. Louis
the city or st. Louis the Chess Club
because there are two separate things
okay I'm gonna take this is reasonable
there's actually a trap resulting from
this position st. Louis's city Forest
Park it's like the best park which I
have only like started discovering over
the past week the last week I've been
taking runs there and it's just it's
incredible Park they have a zoo they
have a bunch of ponds and running paths
they have nature they have racquetball
my opponent says already dead
with dead spelled de D but he okay he's
has a reasonable position like this is
actually a variation of the French
defense where wait oh yeah I'm down a
tempo this is a variation of like the
two Knights attack where usually if I'm
light my knight would be on c6 but my
Knights so on b8 this could be bad
actually
but maybe it's okay there's some tricks
in this position Queen B 3 is really sad
if my knight was on c6 it would be great
but my Knights Nava and c6 so maybe I
Castle
maybe I played Bishop g6
I almost forgot we we hit 10,000 Wow
thanks guys I was so captivated by this
game he didn't take on b7 and he's
giving me the opportunity to greet gift
greet gifts my g4 h5 queen comes in
let's not calculates let's just go for
the kill
and yeah also like another favorite
thing about st. Louis the city is just
essential West End in general it's just
an amazing area like Forest Park
restaurants chess club pretty much
everything you can ask for coffee cartel
favorite sport food what does that even
mean
Oh food spot why I think sport food
favorites food fight food what did I
just say favorite food spots has to be
Thai - OH - it's amazing Thai food if
you ever watched like a been Feingold
lecture and he ends the lecture by
saying time for Thai food it's always
Thai - OH - this is like almost force
meets right this is coming wait a minute
maybe it's not for us mate but it's it's
pretty close
here's an option here between rook e1
and rook t1 and there might be some
difference but maybe not
wherever the rook moves I take on f2
first now it's funny if he were to take
on b7 let's say he included taking on b7
and then I would play like 97 then he
would have a defensive resource Queen
takes e7 defending from afar but then I
would have Knight de5 and I don't know
what's going on there that would have
been an interesting line good thing I
don't have to deal with that he also had
King G 3d I came g3 would have been
interesting actually King g3 yeah maybe
I would play d4 his loose maybe I would
play Queen d6 or h5 I don't know the
King g3 may have been good okay while
this is going to win a rook
but is there more I can take on a one
with check 9f one he's kind of defending
mates Queen h4 King g1 Queen h2 King
Aslan Queen h1 kini to Queen Tai Chi to
King g1 and night take III is not mate
because a rook defends III but Bishop
Bishop h5 Kings c2
okay let's take the rook if he plays
this I probably can just take Ono I
can't
or maybe I can't I don't know because
there's some pin but at this point it's
just a matter of technique maybe I'll
play H 5 H 4 H 3 looks like a nice plan
I don't know how he stops this my rook
is hanging on yeah my rook is hanging
it's ok I'm going for the kill
forgot my work was hanging
that's unfortunate now I actually have
to prove the attack if I play h4 he
takes here I play h3 he takes here and
then he takes here and then he takes on
each three weights now I take on g2
first no it's too risky
well I'm making this interesting maybe I
should just Castle King safety first
he's winning back her rook he's gonna be
up a piece I should have defended b7 I
got so distracted there's so many
subscribers what to do
but yeah thanks guys now now I will
accept congratulations
I was not accepting congratulations
earlier but I appreciate all the support
it's incredible like how many comments I
I get which are just so supportive and
so much support from my opponent not
taking the rook ooh this is gonna be
nasty cuz now Queen take efore there's
not enough to check that turned around
quite quickly
come on it saying oof
with so many O's and the time situation
is not great for white either okay GG
that was a nice gift I was like the
Greek gift followed by many more gifts
should make a new fee motes you came in
thinking I was already at 10k no the
whole point was like celebrating the
lead-up I'm sorry though but now now
it's celebration like this was a good
game to celebrate with who do I play I'm
gonna play the wise wizard because he
came out of nowhere and donated $10 so
wise okay good luck
wise wizard let's play Knight c6 I'll so
he's 1500 like on the dot sometimes
1500s I've never played the game before
but okay let's play e5
do I enjoy karaoke I do not do karaoke
I could freestyle rap but that will have
to take place when I have a hundred
thousand subscribers I'm not doing that
now
Zef cat in the chat all those F cat 50
bits from zeph cat so nice you know what
you know what month it is it's it's um
it's October and in just a few more
weeks it's Halloween so we're gonna play
a reverse Halloween gamete and this is
actually a better version of the normal
Halloween gamete because G 3 Hertz white
because I'm I can't move to G 3 so the
nights a bit more clumsy here it's an
interesting move order for a reverse
halloween gamete like starting with
Knight f3 knight c6 and then somehow we
got there I remember I was doing
preparation in this for a student I
remember studying it and realizing that
like Black has a really nice
compensation like I think the best line
white can get is like plus 0.3 which is
comparable to like many main lines so
it's a playable line for black and so I
win the piece back and I have Queen d5
coming whoo I'll still play Queen d5
this reminds me of some variation in the
center fork trick but White has g3
included which can't be that helpful I
had a lesson with a student earlier who
had like a very similar position and my
student was black their opponent played
queen h5 and my assume was so fixated on
defending f7 he played Bishop e6 but he
missed Bishop d6 because f7 is defended
and the knight is pinned and then just
stuck so queen h5 will make things good
for me
Dahl their move is Knight g4 so there's
also f4 okay we'll see what happens
goodbye my name is Joey thanks for
stopping by and good game you want to
hear me rap
I don't rap like freer in lyrics it
would all be freestyle but I would need
a beat yeah I'll do that probably for
like 100,000 it'll take like another I
don't know how long will it take maybe
another year or two
yeah d4 is probably the best move
wait a minute or it's the worst move
because I can take Anthony this is
attacked and this is attacked he forgot
about the rook this is nice yeah I'll
have to reach out to Mike because he's
he's my sound guy okay so I'm of a rook
good check just gonna continually check
the King wait no my bishop is hanging
but he didn't take it it's funny like
when I sometimes when my blunder
opponents will just trust me my bishops
attacked twice and now retreats up a
rook yeah it's getting late that's a bad
sign thank you this should be for a
check
so I think the goal is to just get this
rook into e2 and then somehow mates the
king maybe Ricky ate
yeah let's Trey the pair of Brooks well
so I can take now let's trade rooks
first
San Diego in the chat San Diego a long
time no see we make San Diego mod a long
time viewer I think he has good
intentions
it's actually pretty cool like there's I
think a good number of viewers who
existed since last year because I
started streaming October last year I
think San Diego is one of the earlier
ones maybe I can take okay let's just
trade down
I just want okay I see one mating idea
maybe he can move his rook here oh
that's not even mate I want to mate on
d1 somehow maybe I should have no I
should have taken on e5 first but it's
okay let's take your here and then mates
he has one move to stop the mates let's
see if he finds it actually two moves ok
that's one of them now the great thing
is I'm just gonna torture him I'm gonna
move pawns for the rest of the game
until he plays King a1 and I'll meet him
it's just inevitable looks wrong
let's play this clever move
yeah it's a pond were like this and now
it's looks like King a-one only leave on
them that was fun this is a nice finish
okay yeah the power it was looks long I
was a fun opening reverse Halloween
gamut this is another thing I'm actually
gonna cover in my course I made an
outline and this is one of the video
lessons
oh so jpp wise wizard was maybe not
watching or not listening with
commentary so in order to watch the
replay you'll have to wait until the
stream ends which I'll probably do
pretty soon unless there's anyone else
who wants to play there's a lot of
people who want to play
I'm really tired I have I have a few
hours of course material to record which
should actually it should be released
within like hopefully by the end of this
month so it's gonna be a course on
aggressive openings for black there will
be more information coming shortly
it's 11:24 p.m. I keep forgetting we did
it we hit 10,000 should screenshots to
my screenshot screenshot this I'll take
a screenshot later yeah I'm gonna end it
there thanks guys for being awesome also
I'll probably put this on YouTube so
thank you to the YouTube audience
YouTube community appreciate everyone's
feedback and support and questions keep
them coming it's going to be a busy
couple couple
more weeks but I'll probably be doing a
lot more YouTube content after October
21st so stay tuned for that
in the meantime lots of people streaming
in the meantime stay tuned I'll probably
end up reading someone at some point
someday but that's yet to be determined
okay so goodnight all I'll see you guys
in the future